FEMALE SPEAKER: Way
back in February,
we reached out to Cliff,
our fearless Talks at Google
leader, and April Whitney,
who's sitting with us today,
Theron's publicist at
Chronicle, about bringing
Maddie and Theron to campus.
After months of
planning, we are so
excited to introduce Maddie
the coonhound and Theron.
We just walked around campus
with Maddie and Theron
and saw her balance
on many a thing.
We'll be posting those
pictures later today.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So you can
look at them on Google+.
The hashtag is going to be
hashtag Maddie on things.
So during the year long
trip across country,
Theron took pictures of
Maddie balancing on everything
from a horse to
open fridge doors.
Some of you might have
seen this on his Instagram
account, Facebook,
all over the web.
They have a great
website and web presence.
So all this culminated
into the book
"Maddie on Things," which led
to Theron's newest project,
"Why We Rescue."
Theron is going to talk about
both of those projects today
and after will be able to
answer some of your questions.
Also, if you don't have a
copy of "Maddie on Things,"
you can buy yours after the
talk in the back from Books Inc.
And then we also have some
Maddie the coonhound shirts
and stickers.
And with that, we would like
to introduce Theron and Maddie.
[APPLAUSE]
THERON HUMPHREY: Yeah,
thanks for having me.
So I've been on the road
seven months this year.
Last year I went to all 50
states shooting a documentary.
And this year we're doing
another 50 state documentary.
And concurrently
with that, we're
doing a 50 state book tour.
So that's like the broad stroke
of what I'm up to this year.
And the Maddie book tour,
hey, that's rolling right now.
And this idea was project.
But it's like since then become
my photo brand and my identity.
You got her?
OK.
Yeah.
So this is the
cover of the book.
You might have seen it.
And the thing that I want to
do and be a part of on the web
is be innovative
with storytelling.
And we also want to do
things that are fresh.
So, like, no one goes and does
a 50 state bookstore, right?
Like, that's kind of crazy.
Like, you normally go to LA and
Las Vegas and New York City.
You go to these
really big places.
But what we wanted to do is
go to all the small towns
and big cities in between.
And we built a really
awesome book tour website.
It's maddieontour.com.
We built it on Meteor.
It's a new web technology.
And it pulls in data from
Instagram and Twitter.
And it archives it on this
really beautiful website.
So if you visited that
site, you could see, like,
our path and our story and
our time together on the road.
Does anyone here program?
Do you all know Meteor?
Yeah.
It's pretty awesome.
It's good stuff.
Most of the people I talk
to don't, like, really
love technology.
So it's cool.
I was actually at
Pixar yesterday.
And that was weird
because I felt
like they should be talking
to me, just like you all
because you all create
really neat things.
And I'm just taking photos
of my dog, you know?
I don't know.
OK, no one's-- I'm
terrible at jokes, I guess.
[LAUGHTER]
But where you come from
is really important.
And Maddie was a side project,
the reason I was traveling.
And so I think the
pleasure I have
of having this quick platform
is I get to tell you what I love
in life and what
I love to create.
And this is where I came from.
Its Pollocksville,
North Carolina.
It's a screen shot
of Google Maps.
You might know Jacksonville.
There's a military base there.
But I grew up on
really sandy soil.
I grew up on a farm.
And that was my home,
and I really I hated it.
Like, I hated where I came from.
But now I love it so much.
Maybe that's your story too.
And this is the last
place that I lived.
This is Sandpoint, Idaho.
So I haven't had an apartment
or house in three years.
And this is about six hours
east of Seattle, so, like,
way up in the mountains.
It's really beautiful,
epic country.
And this is like the scale
of the country, right?
Like, America is huge and vast.
And I went to school
in Savannah, Georgia.
I studied photography.
And I just love to
show this for scale.
And, like, what happens
in life is no one
is really good explaining
that while you're in school
it's essentially a four year
grant to study what you love,
to execute your vision.
Because once you
graduate, you quickly
realize that you start
creating and making
stuff for other people to earn
the money to get them rich.
And for photography
that is so apparent.
So I don't show you--
this is the stuff
I was creating before
I started traveling.
So, like, I don't show you
this work to impress you.
I was shooting
product photography
for a company called
Coldwater Creek.
Like, your mom might
really love it.
My mom loved it.
And this is what had me.
This is my life for
60 hours a week.
You don't go into
the photo studio
and you'd don't shoot one
or two pairs of handbags.
You shoot 35 of these.
And you do it Monday through
Friday, 60, 70 hours a week
sometimes, depending on
if it's holiday season.
There's art directors and
stylists and photographers.
And everyone has
this, Sears and GAP
and Banana Republic and JCPenny.
They all have this whole
world of product photography.
And so you take
something you love,
which is for me photography,
and you can modify it.
And you start pointing
your camera at things
that you don't love and
that you don't believe in.
So then what happens is
Monday through Friday
this is what you shoot.
And then on the weekends you
don't want to pick up a camera.
Like, you do something else.
You go get drunk or go skiing
or backpacking or all three
because you're in Idaho.
And that really did happen,
you know, on the ski hill.
That was me skiing right then.
You got to squish the bugs.
I grew up in the East Coast,
so I didn't grow up skiing.
So my first time, like,
when you ski-- OK,
this is a terrible story.
Like, you just go out there,
and you think you turn.
And then you fall
on you're butt.
But really you have to do this.
That's my ski
lesson for the day.
OK.
Thanks for having me Google.
[LAUGHTER]
But this work that I created
that totally changed my life.
And what happened was
I worked for two years,
and I saved up my
whole week of PTO,
which is Paid Time Off
in the corporate world.
And I took my camera, flew
back to North Carolina just
to visit my granddad.
And I pointed my camera at
what was familiar, the place
I came from.
And this is a still life that
never changed my entire life.
And, like, up in the
right hand corner,
there's this great giraffe.
And you would press the bottom,
and it would collapse over.
And that little thing brought
me so much peace just knowing I
could always know where it was.
That giraffe was always there.
So I just pointed my camera
at the familiar and just
documented the place
that I came from.
This is our tobacco farm,
tobacco barn, rather.
And this is where
I spent my life.
This is where I grew up.
This is my
grandparents right when
they got married, 17 and 18.
And I was hanging with my
grandma a couple months ago.
And she was telling this story.
They didn't have running
water in their house
until she was 18.
They didn't have electricity
until they were 16.
And for me that
just blew my mind.
Like, my life has been so easy.
Like, has anyone, like,
not had clean drinking
water in the United States
or, like, ever gone hungry?
Like, our baseline for
existing is so easy.
In most of the
world, like, those
are the reason for waking up,
to find clean water and to eat.
And for me, I'm just like,
man, life has been so easy.
And it was great just
sitting down with her
and listening to her.
And I photographed my granddad
and recorded his voice.
And he told me
stories of his life.
And this is the tractor that I
grew up riding on the back of.
I would be on the plow
going through the field.
Like, they don't really
plow fields anymore.
It's all no till
farming these days.
But I would go through
the field with him,
and it was so incredible.
And it was just like
a really great week.
I was back where I came from.
I was hanging out
with my granddad.
And then you fly back to Idaho,
and it's like, hey, Theron.
You have 30 pairs of
earings to shoot today.
I'm like, man, this is way
less cool than hanging out
with my granddad.
Like, do these even need
to exist in the world?
That's what I was thinking.
And the following day
I got a phone call.
And my mom was like, hey,
Theron, your granddad
passed away.
So, like, literally,
in a heartbeat,
like, this photograph became
more valuable because you can't
sit down with my granddad
and record his voice.
You can't sit down
and take his portrait.
So now one day when I have
kids I get to be like, hey,
this is your grandfather.
This is what his life was like.
This is what his
voice sounds like.
And I didn't want to be 60 and
wake up and be like, hey, kids,
this was my story.
I was a product photographer.
I made a living.
I have, like, a big 401k,
and here's what I created.
I got to this point
where I would rather
be broke and wake
up every morning
and create something that I
love that I can be proud of.
So what I did, I quit my job.
I went to Kickstarter,
and I presented this idea
that I would travel
all 50 states.
And every single day as I
traversed America and drove
65,000 miles, I
would meet someone,
I would document their life,
I would record their story,
and I would share it on the
web on a website that we built.
And it was this
wide idea because I
was sitting on the sofa
in my place in Idaho.
And I called my best friend.
And I was like, you know,
I want to do something.
And I was like, man, this
is kind of a wild idea.
And I was like, is
thiswildidea.com taken?
Like, it must be, right?
It's such a common phrase.
And it wasn't taken.
So we registered the domain.
And that's where the
project was born from.
And ultimately this project was
National Geographic's travel
project of the year, which
was this incredible honor
at the end of the
year because there's
many days it was
cold and raining.
I was sleeping in the
back of my pickup truck.
And I was meeting
people every day,
and it didn't feel like
anyone was listening.
So at the end, to get a call
from the senior photo editor,
and she was like hey,
Theron, like, come to DC.
We want you to talk
about your project.
I was like, that's so amazing.
And now she follows
me on Instagram,
and she likes my
photos sometimes.
And it's super humbling.
It blows my mind that they're
even looking at what I create.
But yeah this was a huge honor.
And I actually just
looked at the analytics--
[BARKING]
Dogs.
Love dogs.
I actually just looked
at the Google Analytics.
And this website has had over
a terabyte of data pulled off
of it in the past,
like, 18 months.
And I guess in y'alls world
that's not a lot of data.
But for me, just a dude
taking photos-- and the photos
are, like, 50 to 75 k too.
So they're not, like,
these huge files.
And that was incredibly--
this moment, I was like, wow.
Somebody's looking
at what I created.
And this what the
work looks like.
And if you go on the website,
thiswildidea.com there's
30 to 40 photos for each person.
And there's audio of them
telling their stories.
And I just spent
time with people.
I walked up to them,
and I shook their hand
and said you exist, you
matter, you're worthy.
I want to celebrate your life.
And the way I would look at
the project was two ways.
The first is, like, when
recently has any one come up
to you and been like,
what did your grandma cook
that you loved?
Like, what do you
remember about her house?
Like, we don't talk and
engage with life in that way
very often.
So that was, like,
my first level
of engagement with people.
And then they realized that I
wasn't selling them something
and that wasn't trying
to ask them for money.
They just welcomed me into their
lives and into their homes.
And, I don't know,
it's just incredible
when you just walk up to
folks and shake their hand.
And, for me, the new
measure of making work
was that if I feel
uncomfortable in my stomach,
if it flips upside down,
then I need to go do it.
So if you're a creator,
if you're a storyteller,
and waking up every morning
and shooting in the Golden Gate
Bridge in fog doesn't make
you feel uncomfortable,
like, I want to encourage you
to go shoot something else
that does because I think
that's how you really
grow as an artist, as a
storyteller and image maker.
And I promise you, walking
up to a rancher in Wyoming
is terrifying.
I don't know.
Maybe that sitting here
in Google headquarters
doesn't feel that way.
But go out into the world
and walk on someone's land
with this interest of
wanting to hear their story.
It's terrifying in
the best of ways.
And I think the
best way to think
about my work and this project--
and I tell this whole story.
And it connects to
Maddie because this
is the reason why the
Maddie book exists.
She was traveling with me for
this whole year on the road.
And the best way to
think about my work
is if there's a box on
your front door right now.
You know it's delivered.
You check the UPS
because that's what I do.
I want to know when
it's out for delivery.
And inside that box was an
audio recording, 30, 45 seconds,
and 10 photographs of
your mom when she was 18.
So, like, someone
sat down with her
and recorded her
voice, what she wanted
to do in life, what she was
passionate about, what she
loved, and then just
took a portrait of her.
Like, opened up her
fridge and photographed
the inside of her fridge,
what was in it that day.
Now fast forward
30, 40 years later.
Like, what would
those images be worth?
Would you want to
leave right now
to go listen to what
she sounded like?
I would love to know
what my mom sounded like,
what she wanted to
do with her life.
And that's what
this work was about.
It's about celebrating the
every day, the ordinary.
And I don't know.
It's so damn simple.
But I think it just resonated
with folks in the right way.
And there's this
horse on the ranch.
And the other amazing
part of the story
is my dog came with me.
This is Maddie.
And if you've been
following for a while,
you actually know
she is pointing
the incorrect direction.
So, like, I kind of
started to fall in love
with photographing
her this way because I
liked her spots
better on this side.
And how Maddie came
to my life is--
and this is her
on four soup cans.
But right before I started
traveling, I got on Petfinder.
And I was like I need a dog for
my adventure across America.
And, you know,
Steinback had Charlie.
And was like, I'm born
and raised in the south.
I need a coonhound
to come with me.
So I got on Petfinder.
And the first one that
popped up was Maddie.
And I was like, oh, my gosh.
She looks like a deer.
That's so amazing.
So I went to see her at
the shelter that day.
And I played with her.
And she was fantastic,
but very aloof.
And as I was walking to put
her back into the cage--
because I wasn't sure.
I was, like, in my
truck for a whole year.
So, like, you know,
I wasn't going
to be able to leave my dog
at home for eight hours.
She was always with me.
I was walking back
into the cage,
and she pressed her body against
my leg the whole way back.
And I was like, I can't
put you back in there.
It's so sad.
So I walked up to adopt her.
And I thought it was going to
be this long paperwork process.
And it was $40.
I was like, OK, so
I own a dog now.
It was really quite that simple.
It all happened in,
like, six hours.
Like, Petfinder, visit
Maddie, adopt her.
Now I have a dog in my life.
And I had no idea
what I was doing.
And this is one of
the first photos that
got a lot of traction
around the world.
Like, "People" magazine
published this photo.
Man, this image actually
has a really crazy story.
I was in South Dakota, and I
was eating lunch in my tailgate.
So, like, when you
travel with a dog,
you quickly realize that you
don't eat in a restaurant.
You get your food to go
or you get a sandwich,
and you eat it on your tailgate.
And your dog can run around
and play in the woods.
And I was on some
land on a dirt road.
And a big diesel
truck passes me.
And I was like, oh,
I'm on this guy's land.
He's going to get upset.
But he tipped his hat at me.
So I was like, OK, we're cool.
I can be here.
And he parked his truck and took
his horse out of his trailer.
And I got that feeling
inside my stomach.
I was like, I need to
go engage with this guy
and shake his hand.
And I want to hear his story.
And I walked up to him.
I'm was like, hey, I'm Theron.
This is my dog Maddie.
And I was like,
you know, my dog is
really good at
standing on things.
Could she stand on your horse?
Right.
A really common thing to do.
And he looks at me in the eye.
And he goes, I know who you are.
I seen you in "People" magazine.
I was like, that's so crazy.
I was in the middle of
nowhere South Dakota,
and he had seen the work.
But, yeah, I mean,
I think this is
just what you do when you
travel for an entire year
with your dog.
Like, maybe like I'm a
mother with a new child.
[BARKING]
Yeah, the work grew out
of just her natural talent
and desire to climb things,
get up on trees, on rocks.
I think the other thing
that I came to love
was the entire book is
shot on the iPhone 4.
So, like, every
image inside it is
iPhone 4, which
is kind of crazy.
And here's the other really
insane thing about it.
So Instagram came
about this time
when I was doing this
project, so two years ago.
And I didn't have a community
of people around me.
I was on the road by
myself using this app.
So I didn't shoot
through the native camera
and then upload it.
I was shooting, literally,
through the Instagram app.
So I have one photo of
each of these moments,
and there's no
outtakes or alternative
frames on the other side.
So it's literally one
image, much like a Polaroid.
I just thought that's how
you're supposed to use it,
like, you get one take
much like you literally
would a Polaroid photo,
which is really crazy
to think about now.
Like, I would never shoot
like that these days.
But it was so great.
Just, like, you get into to
respond of shape and line
and space.
Like, this is Portland,
Oregon at Voodoo Donuts.
And then it's
like, I don't know,
put your dog in the basket.
And then it just makes
the photo better.
You guys are, like,
totally unsure
of everything I'm
talking about up here.
But this is an
incredible example
of why you should never
eat inside a restaurant
because you miss the woman with
the Poodles on her sweater.
And I was sitting under a tree
eating, and she was walking by.
And I was like, can my
dog stand on your walker?
And she's like, yeah, sure.
And then Maddie's
like, no big deal.
I can do that.
And then you take a photo
and you upload it instantly
to the internet.
And then it just happens
so quickly just like that.
And in my mind I was like
what would the mailman do
if he opens the mailbox and
there's this dog in there?
And so many of the photos
just happened on a whim.
Like, my friend jokingly opened
both the doors to the fridge.
I was like, oh, Maddie
should stand up there.
And then you place her.
Stay, Maddie.
And take a photo.
Upload it.
And give her a treat.
And so, like, all these
images kind of just
happened so quickly.
I literally took the photo and
then uploaded it within, like,
10 seconds of making the image.
And then, like, 500,000 people
see that image on their phone.
And it just blows my mind,
that idea that the image goes
into space and then it comes
back to people's phones,
and they share this
moment with you.
Like, my dog was here on
the Golden Gate Bridge.
I don't know.
I'm not articulating
the idea that well.
But it's just special.
Yeah, and we celebrated
birthdays on the road together.
And she was always with me.
You start to do weird things
with your dog, I think.
I was, like, driving.
I was like, hey, Maddie.
I think it's your birthday.
And then it's like,
what are we going to do?
It's like, I don't know.
Let's get you a birthday hat.
And then you're in
the Dollar Store,
and you see this little banner.
And you're like, I don't know.
Let's take a photo.
I'm not crazy dog
person, I promise.
I don't know.
Maybe I am.
This is the levee
in New Orleans.
This the levee that
broke down there.
That's my good buddy,
Michael Tucker.
And, like, I love
showing this image.
We think, conceptually,
what's fascinating
about photography is
often what you choose
not to show in the frame
is more important and more
valuable than what is in
the frame to create a story.
So what I mean by that is,
like, the basketball goal
is cranked down low.
But literally right
outside the frame
is my pickup truck that
has a camper shell.
So Maddie is only about
a foot off the ground.
So I never intentionally try to
create work that upsets people.
But I also don't want to be
that guilty of photographing
cliches, like just shooting my
dog on a beach during sunset.
But, historically,
like, another example
of including things in the
frame and not including them
is a famous image by Dorothy
Elaine during the FSA
during the Great Depression.
There's this migrant mother
image of her and her child.
But she intentionally,
in the dark room,
Photoshopped-- that's
a weird analogy saying
darkroom and Photoshop together.
But she, in the dark room,
took out the husband's hand.
So it created this, like,
story of his destitute woman
and her child by herself without
this strong man there with her.
So the idea of not including
something in the photograph
is just as valuable
as what you do show.
So I don't always think
about photography like that.
But the frames
are really strong.
Yeah, you know.
I don't know.
Maddie, can you
stand across this?
And then she's like,
yeah, no big deal.
I can do that.
And then you take
a photograph of it.
And, you know, just waking up
with Maddie every single day.
[BARKING]
I really wish I could
just print this image
huge on my wall and--
[BARKING]
Are you OK, Maddie?
She's like, why am I
all the way in the back?
Maddie is not a leash dog.
And I think Google
is a leash campus.
We normally spend
most of our days
in open fields in the woods.
So she just wants to explore.
Yeah, and, you
know, just driving
with my dog, spending
time with her.
And the work evolved
and changed over time.
Shes' just a good sport
and a good subject.
And then, like, you'd just
be walking by a garage
and just responding--
hey, Maddie, yeah.
And just responding to objects.
And, you know, you see this
Easy Rider helmet in the garage.
And you start asking
questions like can
Maddie where this helmet?
And quickly the answer is
yes, she can wear the helmet.
And it's the photograph.
This is waking up with her
and spending time with Maddie.
That's my buddy [? Moneal ?].
So I fell in love
with this idea of
how, like, dog and
man melt together.
And you start just
exploring that.
It comes so simple.
Like, he was laying
on the couch,
just kind of being
silly, fake sleeping.
And I was like, oh, Maddie
should lay on top of you.
And I started
asking this question
of how would Maddie
wave to me if she could?
I don't think she
would use her paws.
Like, what if she
could control her ears?
It would be so wonderful
if she could do that.
So that's where
the work came from.
We were at South by Southwest
where this tour started some
seven months ago.
And we were at my buddy's house.
And I saw this guitar case.
And I was like, oh, Maddie
should totally sit in it.
So I told her to
sit and lay down.
And then she just fell
asleep in the case.
And I was like, OK.
You can stay there
if you want to.
Coonhounds, like, totally
love to curl up in small balls
and get in tiny places.
And then this is definitely
one of my favorite images.
And, no, they're not
chocolate sprinkles.
So you don't have to
email me afterwards.
But I was like, Maddie
does everything all in.
And I feel like if
she wanted ice cream,
she'd just, like, dive her face
into the bowl of ice cream.
And then you're in
the grocery store,
and you're walking
by the pineapple,
and you think of the
Chiquita banana woman.
And you're like, can
Maddie where a pineapple?
And you buy a pineapple.
And the answer is yes.
She can wear pineapple.
Hey, Maddie.
Hey.
And, man, she is such a good
sport and such a good model.
I just love that
little bit of tongue.
And that's what becomes
really great about photography
is often it hinges on one
tiny element and tiny moment.
Like, with this image, if her
tongue wasn't sticking out,
it would lose so
much of the power
and, like, what made it special.
The other really scary
thing about photography--
I've been thinking
about more of it
recently-- is, like,
when you sit down
to edit your photos after you
shot the day or the concept,
and you're going through them,
and you get to the last photo,
and you choose that image,
like, it makes me so nervous.
Like, what if I didn't
shoot that one more frame?
What if I didn't
click once more?
I'm like, am I teetering,
like, that much on life
where it's just like this
half of a second decision?
Because so often you're
like, OK, I got it.
I got this photo.
You're like, no, no.
One more.
And then you choose that.
Oh, it makes me so
anxious to think about it
if I didn't shoot
that photograph.
Insights into my mind.
And this photograph has
a crazy story on the web.
So for the bookstore
we're on right now,
we were shooting the video
for talk it to promote it.
And we were in the store,
in the Cafe, rather.
And I was thinking "Seinfeld."
So at the end of
the shoot, I was
like, oh, let's pour
Maddie a cup of coffee,
ask her to sit on the
stool, put her paws up.
My buddy started pouring coffee.
I'm shooting with my phone,
and she starts yawning.
I'm like, oh, my gosh.
This is amazing because
you couldn't recreate
this photograph if
you had $100,000.
This is so serendipitous.
And this photo took
on a life of its own.
This is just a tiny example.
And they're ultimately
really great folks.
But So Delicious,
they took the photo,
they, like, poorly Photoshopped
their product into it
and, like, put it
out there on the web.
So really just, like,
blatant and disrespectful use
of photography and, like,
breaking copyright laws.
And it just really
broke my heart.
And I was like, well, let's
turn this bad situation
into something really good.
So I went to Facebook.
And I was like wouldn't it
be great if So Delicious
donated $10,000 to an animal
shelter for stealing my photo?
And through a couple
of phone calls
I received from So
Delicious, they're
like, that's going to be the
greatest idea ever, Theron.
Let's do that--
just because by law
they would have been on
the hook for a lot more.
And then through about
6,000 suggestions
and tweets and emails
later, So Delicious
did give $10,000 to a
shelter in Chicago that
puts elderly animals into
good homes, which is, like,
a super tough sell in
that world if you're
involved in animal rescue
or adoption at all.
So this year, concurrently
with this 50 state book tour
we're doing, I was like,
this isn't quite easy enough.
I was like, let's shoot
another 50 state documentary.
So the way that I look at
photography and creating work
is Maddie is this
beautiful pop song.
And it's fun, and it's
like a catalyst and a entry
to my other work.
And then I want to
create documentaries
and shoot projects that are
driven by the heart and much
more salt of the earth
and have personal value
and social value.
So, you know, I
didn't intentionally
get into the dog world.
But what I quickly realized
is that I didn't want my place
to be showing sad
dogs behind sad cages
because Maddie was a rescue
dog at a high kill shelter.
And she changed my life.
And I don't want
to promote the idea
that these dogs in your
local shelter are bad dogs
or abused or not
worthy of your home.
The truth is two out of
three dogs in America
that still find homes in America
aren't from shelters or rescue
groups.
And I just I want to suggest and
tell the story that if you're
looking to bring an
animal into your life,
go to the Humane Society.
Go to the animal shelter.
Go to your local rescue group
and check those dogs out.
And this is what the
project is about.
It's storytelling and
spending time with people
and celebrating their life.
And if we go whywerescue.com,
as every state we traverse
America, there's a
new story posted.
And there's audio
and photography.
And I think the other great
thing about creating projects
at this scale-- so, like,
so much of the internet
is a hot flash.
It's, like, boom, bang.
Here's your ad.
Here you go.
But when you create
work like this
that's over the course
of an entire year,
people can invest in it.
They can check back
with it once a week.
There's always a new
story to be posted there.
And so I think people
get much more invested
and in tune with the
project and the spirit
of what you're creating
instead of just
being something fleeting.
So that's kind of like
how I look at photography
now and on the web.
So, like, build and
awesome, custom website.
Build it so it works
great on mobile.
And then invest
in it over a year.
That's what I'm into,
just telling stories.
And this is my really
good buddy, Garret, AKA
really kind of amazing on the
Instragrams if you use that.
And so this year has been
super expensive for us.
So we're driving
40,000, 50,000 miles.
And the way that we're
supplementing our gas bill
is we, ourselves, hand screen
printed some really nice
t-shirts.
So if you are into Maddie, I
would love to sell you a shirt
because it helps out
our gas tank so much.
And they're on, like, the
best shirts made in America.
It's the good stuff.
And then, man, I love the next
slide because I love stickers.
And actually I
found this-- I think
Google use-- this
is Sticker Robot.
I found them because
I think you all
have ordered stickers
from them before.
But they're, like,
the best stickers.
They're UV coated.
And they last, like,
five years outside.
And we got stickers too.
And I think they're super rad.
I get pumped on stickers.
And this is just a
little slide of what
I have planned for next year.
And this is the book that
we're pitching right now.
And it's "Maddie the Coonhound,
a Super Serious Project
About a Dog and a Motorcycle."
So the plan is to
traverse all of America
with my dog in a side car
and me on a motorcycle.
And we're just going to
go on this adventure.
And I think it's just going
to be a blast and just
a ton of fun.
So that's, like, what we're
looking for for next year
to go create.
And then this year, hey,
if you do have the book
or you wanted it, like, I
made Maddie's paw prints,
her little paw
print, into a stamp.
So I'd love to stamp your book.
I would love to sign your--
I can sign my name too.
I would like to do that.
Yeah, and I would love to
hear what you guys create.
I also have
suggestions of what you
could do better
if you need those.
I'm just kidding.
That was a bad joke.
This is being recorded.
But yeah, do we have time
for if you have a question?
AUDIENCE: So what is
her favorite reward?
In some of those
pictures, it looks
like she was
stretched pretty far.
THERON HUMPHREY: Right.
Yeah, I mean, Maddie is
really just simple, you know.
She'll eat anything, you know.
AUDIENCE: And then have
you ever measured--
on that one where
she's on the hand
rails-- have you ever
measured her length, like,
how far she can go?
THERON HUMPHREY: I haven't.
I think that was, like,
the ultimate stretch,
that one on the hand rails.
Yeah, but I never put
a tape measure to it.
I guess I need to.
But she's about 45 pounds or so.
AUDIENCE: Do you close
her eyes by herself?
THERON HUMPHREY: Yeah.
It's just, like, a
lot of-- I should
have had some more images
here speaking to that.
But I guess the
sprinkled nose has it.
But, yeah, it's just a
moment I choose to share.
So, like, we were on the
"Today Show" recently.
And she was sitting in
the stool next to me.
And I look over, and her head's
down, and her eyes are closed,
and she's just sleeping.
I was like, oh,
Maddie, that's great.
But, yeah, it's just a
moment within the time
that I'm taking the photo
that she just, like,
Zens out and, like,
just shuts her eyes.
I don't know.
I always thought
it was super cute.
That's why I choose
to share those images.
Yes, ma'am?
AUDIENCE: So how did
she come to the shelter?
And how old was she
when you adopted her?
And how long have you had her?
THERON HUMPHREY: She was about
a year old when I got her.
And, sadly, I don't know
any of her back story.
She just got dropped off.
But her name was Madi,
M-A-D-I, when I rescued her.
So I was like, we got
spell it differently.
So I just changed
the spelling of it.
But, yeah, I mean, like,
one of my Maddie wishes
would be to get to meet her
mom and dad and have, like,
puppy photos of her.
That would be so
great because I'm
sure she had amazing
ears as a puppy.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming
to hang out with us.
I'm sorry we're so
quiet and reserved.
THERON HUMPHREY: It's OK.
AUDIENCE: I wish we could,
like, be a little closer
and get more into what
you're talking about.
I guess my question
is-- you must,
I mean, with the Why
We Rescue project,
you must connect a lot with
both specific people who
rescue animals and also
with organizations.
Do you have any
particular stories
you want to share about, like,
really magical rescue stories?
THERON HUMPHREY:
Actually I don't
connect with organizations.
I think they're out
there, and they're
doing really awesome work.
But, for me, it's about
telling the individual stories
without affiliation to a group.
And, for me, I'm
just a storyteller.
And I want to get people
excited about rescuing dogs
and then go out and find
the organization that
makes the most sense for them.
But, I mean, the stories vary.
The project can be as simple
as, like, waking up and, like,
I need a dog in my life.
And you go to a shelter
and you pick one.
Like, that's not that
profound of a story.
But that's what we're
celebrating because you
literally change that
animal's life in that moment,
and that's worthy of
documenting and sharing.
And then you have other
stories on the website where
I met this really
wonderful girl.
She graduated college and was,
like, a little lost in life
like we all had been,
or I was as well.
And she's like, I
need a sailboat.
So she spent, like,
$2,000 or $3,000,
bought a cheap
sailboat, sailed down
the Mississippi without
knowing how to sail,
learned to sail along the way,
and brought her dog with her.
And that's just like
this incredible story,
right, of risk and adventure
and, like, a big question mark.
So, like, I don't know.
If you leave anything
from here today,
like, I just want
to encourage you,
shake you by the shoulders,
and say that, like,
choosing not to
go on an adventure
or create work
that's your vision
isn't just a simple
yes or no question.
If you are choosing
to put it off,
that's, like, a whole
attitude towards life.
It's not just a single moment.
Hey, Google, thanks
so much for having me.
It's been a pleasure.
Maybe next time we
can sit in a circle.
I don't know.
We can hold hands
next time and talk.
Yeah.
But, yeah, thanks so
much for having me.
Thanks for the venue.
I totally appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]